we don't think we hate cheap things but
we frequently behave as if we rather do
consider the pineapple Columbus was the
first European to be delighted by its
physical grandeur and vibrant sweetness
he brought some back to Europe the
pineapples proved extremely difficult to
transport and very costly to cultivate
for a long time only royalty could
afford to eat them
Russia's Catherine the Great was a huge
fan as was charles ii of england a
single fruit in the 17th century sold
for today's equivalent of five thousand
pounds the pineapple was so exciting and
so loved that in 1761 the fourth Earl of
Dunmore built a temple on his Scottish
estate in its honor and Christopher Wren
had no hesitation in topping the South
Tower of st. Paul's in London with his
evidently divine fruit then at the very
end of the 19th century two things
changed large commercial plantations of
pineapples were established in Hawaii
and there were huge advances in
steamship technology transport costs
plummeted and unwittingly transformed
the psychology of pineapple eating today
you can get a pineapple for a round of
pound 50 it still tastes exactly the
same but now the pineapple is one of the
world's least glamorous fruits it's
never served smart dinner parties and it
would never be carved on top of the
major Civic building the pineapple
itself hasn't changed only our attitude
to it hands contemplation of history of
the pineapple suggests a curious overlap
between love and economics when we have
to pay a lot for something nice we
appreciate it to the full yet as its
price in the market Falls passion has a
habit of fading away naturally the
object has no merit to begin with a high
price won't be able to do anything for
it but if it has real virtue and yet a
low price then it's in severe danger of
falling into neglect it's a pattern that
we see recurring in a range of areas for
example with a sight of clouds from
above in 1927 a hitherto unknown airmail
pilot called Charles Lindbergh became
the first man to complete a solo
crossing of the Atlantic in
plane the spirit of st. Louis he was
awestruck and felt he was becoming for a
time almost godlike for most of the 20th
century his experience remained rare and
extremely costly there was therefore
never any danger that the human value of
crossing an ocean by air would be
overlooked but this lasted only until
the arrival of the Boeing 747 and the
cheap plane ticket in the summer of 1970
now almost no one looks out of the plane
window anymore why then do we associate
cheap prices with a lack of value our
response seems a hangover from our long
pre-industrial past for most of human
history that truly was a strong
correlation between cost and value the
higher the price the better things
tended to be because there was simply no
way both for prices to be low and
quality high everything had to be made
by hand by expensively trained artisans
with raw materials that were immensely
difficult to transport the expensive
sword jacket window wore wheelbarrow
were simply always the better ones this
relationship between price and value
held true in an uninterrupted way until
the end of the 18th century when thanks
to the Industrial Revolution something
extremely unusual happened human beings
worked out how to make high-quality
goods at cheap prices because of
technology and new methods of organizing
the labor force however despite the
greatness of these efforts instead of
making wonderful experiences universally
available industrialization has
inadvertently produced a different
effect it seemed to rob certain
experiences of their loveliness interest
and worth its not of course that we
refuse to buy inexpensive or cheap
things
it's just that getting excited over
cheap things has come to seem a little
bizarre one is allowed to get very
worked up over the eggs of the sturgeon
100 pounds for a small pot but we have
to be very circumscribed about one's
enthusiasm for the eggs of a chicken
1200 pounds there is an intimidating
hierarchy operating in the background
shaping what we're allowed to be
grateful for and feel that we lack and
must have the price tells us something
very special is going on here
but it may be going on in the cheaper
thing - how do we reverse this the
answer lies in a slightly unexpected
area the mind of a four-year-old here he
is with a puddle it started raining an
hour ago now the street is full of
puddles and there could be nothing
better in the world the riches of the
Indies would be nothing next to the
pleasures of being able to see the
rippling of the water created by a jump
in one's boots Eddie's and whirlpools
the minut waves the oceans beneath one
it's all fascinating children have great
advantages they don't know what they're
supposed to like and they don't
understand money so price is never a
guide of value for them they'll spend an
hour with one button one buys them the
forty nine pound wooden toy made by
Swedish artisans and finds that they
prefer the cardboard box that it came in
they prefer the nail and screw section
of the DIY shop to the fanciest toy
department a child might be deeply
surprised even shocked to learn that a
USB stick can be had for just over 1
pound children would be right if prices
were determined by human worth and value
but they're not they just reflect what
things cost to make the pity is
therefore that we do treat them as a
guide to what matters when this isn't
what a financial price should ever be
useful we can't directly go back to
childhood but we have got people who can
help us in this area artists they are
the experts at recording and
communicating their enthusiasms which
like children can take them in slightly
unexpected directions the French artist
Paul Susanne spent a good deal of the
late 19th century painting groups of
apples in his studio in Provence
he was thrilled by their texture shapes
and colors
he loved the transitions between the
yellowy gold and the deep reds across
their skins suzanne had all the all love
and excitement before the Apple that
aristocrats once had for the pineapple
Suzanne in his studio was generating his
own revolution not an industrial
revolution that would make once costly
objects available to everyone
but a revolution in appreciation a far
deeper process that could get us to
notice what we already have to have
and instead of reducing prices he was
raising levels of appreciation which is
a move that's perhaps more precious to
us economically because it means that we
can suddenly get a lot more great things
for very little money we need to rethink
our relationship to prices we've been
looking at prices in the wrong way we
fetishize them as tokens of intrinsic
value we've allowed them to set how much
excitement we're allowed to have in
given areas but prices would never
mentally like this we're breathing too
much life into them and therefore
dulling too many of our responses to the
inexpensive world we are astonishingly
already a good deal richer than we're
encouraged to think we are
you